someone just woke up from a coma they've
been in a coma for ten years they
haven't seen any of the 18 Marvel movies
what do you tell them how do you catch
them up quickly and succinctly on where
we are now
anybody first I would probably have to
find out the details of what caught them
in a coma right maybe let them know
primarily like you know did they did
they lose anyone in the accident you
know what's their personal life who's
their wife with right right break back
okay I can do that no one else was hurt
in the accident good their wife did
remarry very quickly the guy before she
even found out there was an accident
which is kind of creepy I smell I'm just
gonna straight up I smell foul play yeah
what what about what about short-term
memory loss because that would dictate
how quickly we have to tell him you have
to tell them they their memory recycles
every 45 seconds so this has to be a
very quick summation of what's going on
in this latest Marvel iteration of the
Avengers what do you do what do you say
god just watch the full movies outside
movies or and that gets you there yeah
there are 17 move or 18 mundo say this
is 19 17 of 18 movies okay moving
forward you have to assume that if a
person just wakes up out of a coma
there's still gonna be some time in the
hospital for testing I think you know
listen you're gonna spend at least 40
hours here yeah the entire world has
invested at least 40 hours over the
course of past ten years to get caught
up on the interlocking into open
storylines of all these great Marvel
characters you get to do it from the
comfort of your hospital beds and and
boom you start with you know Downey and
five rows first Iron Man and you work
all the way through the the soso movies
then you get into guardians McGowan
seemed to brighten up a lot on garden to
the ignorant guardian the galaxy like
you were filled with a new excitement
and energy for that was that yeah
oh I mean I think you can see it on
tanked when you're dealing with someone
who's been recently in a coma it's
important to have big facial expressions
I was just wanted to keep him engaged
none of you have seen oh I'm sorry go
ahead
no no I was gonna check if there was a
DVD player in the hospital but that's
what doesn't you know I want to say that
both Chris's got really bogged down in
the details of the coma which I didn't
get to be distracting and not helpful I
thought it was a fairly simple question
attention was it was simple I would have
gone that route right it was a grout you
would have brought enjoyed the journey
you enjoy the journey we took but in a
way it was an incredible waste of time
for all of you who have things to do
scarlet has to be gone in what five
minutes scarlet you need to wait you
have to make big facial expressions when
somebody comes out of a coma yes because
just about to freak them out
don't think that might frighten them who
are you that I don't want to see that
when I come out of a coma you dick move
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
you